Mark Phillips is in Paris where the
president could say more about Russia
later today market morning to you good
morning well this is the briefest of
visits here and it's official purpose
and what really may happen here might be
quite different things the president is
officially here because tomorrow is the
French national holiday Bastille Day a
big parade down the
shawn's alizée including this time
American troops commemorating the entry
of the u.s. into World War one a hundred
years ago but if this was a build or
thought to be any kind of respite from
domestic politics at home it may not
turn out to be because the president is
also having a meeting with the French
president Emmanuel macron following that
they will hold a brief the briefest of
news conferences each president is going
to take two questions we're told from
the press here so that if the president
some thought that this was in any way a
diversion from domestic concerns well it
may not turn out to be Jeff Mark
Phillips in Paris mark thank you very
much when the two presidents speak after
their meeting we'll bring you a CBS News
special report it is expected to start
around 12:15 p.m. Eastern 11:15 a.m.
Central